[Musique]
les chiffres du nombre de contaminations
aux qu'ovide largement au dessus des
objectifs fixés pour le déconfinement
environ 11000 cas ces dernières 24
heures la courbe effectivement arrête de
descendre elle se stabilise
donc ce sera difficile d'atteindre ça
c'est vrai que ça avait bien baissé et
puis là il y à une stagnation alors
est-ce que c'est lié au fait que avec la
réouverture d'un certain nombre de
commerces et on adaptera nos nos proches
nos préconisations au bon sens des
français qui ont déjà parfaitement
compris l'importance du respect des
mesures individuelles et collectives
les premières doses du vaccin anti
qu'ovide à l'intérieur de cette boîte
elles ont été livrées dans cet hôpital
universitaire de crohn donne près de
londres pour vous retenez vous oui je me
ferai vacciner dès qu'il sera disponible
et en public
j'attends de voir les résultats ce que
j'ai toujours pas vu d'étude
scientifique sérieuse sur ces deux
vaccins d'ailleurs j'ai dénoncé cet
excès de précipitation
enfin montre qu'en tant que scientifique
ça me gêne donc maintenant je vais pas
me faire vacciner
les vaccins contre attaque ce groupe
d'une dizaine d'anonymes créé en 2017
s'est donné un objectif faire la guerre
aux fausses informations qui circulent
au sujet de la vaccination
la première campagne de vaccination
devrait débuter début janvier première
vaccination dès le 4 janvier dans les
hépatites tout se passe bien mais
personne ne sera obligé de se faire
vacciner
composé de doctorant en biologie de
fonctionnaires ou encore d'ingénieurs le
groupe des vaccins assure agir par pur
intérêt de santé publique
ces vaccins vont expérimenter jeudi l'a
expérimenté une méthode vaccinale
notamment la rn messager et les
thérapies géniques qui n'ont jamais été
testé sur l'homme qui n'ont jamais été
testées à taille humaine sur des
épidémies comme celle ci l'a dans les
airs sur combien de personnes 40 milles
voilà le programme moins que j'ai eu
jusqu'à présent ça me paraissait de la
science fiction
donc pour l'instant
ce que j'ai vu c'est surtout de la
publicité je n'ai pas vu d'articles
scientifiques j'attends de voir des
vraies données
je suis assez d'accord avec ce problème
de méfiance parce que ça va trop vite en
fait les médias et les politiques vont
plus vite que les scientifiques pour
avoir les données
alors ce matin dans les colonnes du jdd
alain fischer le monsieur vaccin du
gouvernement dévoile ses pistes pour
restaurer la confiance grâce à des
messages bien fait ciblé répété en
évitant les arguments d'autorité les
injonctions émanant des responsables
sanitaires une visite d'état qui fait
parler emmanuel macron a reçu
aujourd'hui à l'élysée le président
égyptien abdel fattah al sisi
ça n'est pas un message de la france à
l'égard de votre religion ou du monde
musulman
c'est l'expression libre de quelqu'un
qui en effet provoque blasphème il a le
droit dans mon pays parce que ça n'est
pas la loi de l'islam qui s'applique
c'est la loi d'un peuple souverain qu'il
a choisie pour lui même et je ne vais
pas la changer pour vous je pense que si
on s'amusait à faire ce vaccin
obligatoire
vous auriez une révolution c'est vrai
qu'à le faire c'est pas le cas tu m'as
fait beaucoup beaucoup de l'allemagne
aux couleurs gris amont vettel mais
tellement naïve oui elle vous fait des
nouveaux cas on d'amour doit en attaque
aux badauds de fauconnerie au dragon age
je m'excuse de vous faire la paix mais
tout ça c'est des peurs parisienne ça
vous avez une vision du monde près que
le monde est entièrement comme paris
mais c'est pas vrai moi mal à paris que
dans certaines régions avons rigolé il
ya plus de morts dans l'est de france
que dans toute la chine dans nos pays je
crois que si nous considérons que le
religieux supplante le politique dans
l'ordre qui est le sien ou est supérieur
à l'ordre des hommes alors ça n'est plus
nous qui gouverne un pays sur une base
qui est celle de d'un principe
démocratique c'est autre chose ce sont
des théocraties ce n'est pas l'ordre que
nous avons choisi il y en a eu dans
l'histoire
je ne pense pas que cela amène aux
meilleurs